abone ol
ve tasarım şimdi kapanmasına güzel
zalimin yumruklarına oklarına
Dur dur yeter
ve Hoca uyumazsa yalnız bildirebilir
misin acıların değil çektiğim için
ömürler
bu görebilirsiniz bunda oluyor
Az önce uykularında sıyrıldığımız zaman
yaşamak kaygısından gidişler görebiliriz
şu Melek olur
Az önce lazım şimdi dayanabilir zamanın
kırbacına Gururun çiğnenmesine
sevgisinin kepaze edilmesine kanunların
bu kadar yavaş üstünün bu kadar hızlı
Yıldız olmasın
bir bıçak saplayıp göğsüne kusmak varken
şimdi uyanmak istersin bunlara hayatını
al
abone ol
Ve aleykümselam korkmakta nsa kimsenin
gidip dönemedi bilinmez Dünya nüfusu
seviyor
Bu nedir bel alacaksın vatansa
çektiklerine razı gelmişsiniz
de böyle kompakt ediyor hepinizi
düşünceniz onu bir şey bulandırıyor
rehberlerimiz davranıyor İşte sırf bu
yüzden onu nice iç atmışlar yollarını
değiştirip iş eylem olma gücünü
itiyorlar
çok güzel otele geliyor Geri kızı
bağlarında unutmadım şimdi e e e e